Stephanie's in Virginia hi Stephanie how
are you I'm doing better than I deserve
what's up so my husband um has an email
in come on we don't really know what his
paychecks will be on every two weeks and
he gets paid and we've gone through
Financial Peace University and what's
there on baby step one we were close to
get the thousand and then I had car
issues so unfortunately Murphy's Law has
been I'm sorry did you go through
Financial Peace University watch yeah
March
then you what's your household income
the household income taken is about um
I'm sorry think it's 50 and we had
before taxes you make sixty seventy
thousand dollars a year and since March
you haven't come up with a thousand
dollars what happened my name I know
yeah I did excuse-excuse like I said
what happened like my car went down I
had medical bills and all these other
issues I guess my biggest question is
about the health and valley that you
always talk about I wondering of
understanding of how you will cooperate
in that because I know your hell you I'm
read a little bit about the hills the
valley but I'm not a hundred percent
sure what that would be for someone that
has an irregular income that is extreme
like they had so much they have no
income and other months they have a huge
income okay cuz my husband he can have
like a great paycheck say you know to
run the household about to to pay bills
and have food sometimes he has that
sometimes he has $500 one time he was
$600 short so it goes up and down and
sometimes he could be fixed on the
dollar short in two paychecks yeah but
then it comes back in the other checks
so it's not it's not six thousand short
it's six hundred so the e regular the
irregular income
planning sheet in your budget forms that
you got in Financial Peace University go
back and re-watch the budgeting lesson
again re listen to the budgeting lesson
again you've got access to all of that
still you flunked that course so you
need to go back and because the original
income just is a prioritized spending
plan on the portion of your income that
is unpredictable and so if you have a
sixty or seventy thousand dollar a year
income that means your take-home pay is
four thousand dollars a month give or
take and if but but that's the average
and sometimes it's down as low as three
thousand and you come up short and other
times it's as high as six or seven
thousand and so what you do is you run a
regular budget on the amount that you
can count on which in my example there
would be the three thousand dollar
amount okay and then you run a
prioritized spending plan on anything
that you didn't get to in your regular
budget on three thousand dollars and the
prioritize spending plan is simply
you're listing your debts or you're
listing your things that you didn't get
to most important that I didn't get to
to least important that I didn't get to
and those are those things almost in
your situation they will almost never
include necessities and so you guys have
continued to live without a budget while
you were in the class and after you got
out of the class and you've continued to
not write it down you've continued to
just make money and try to survive and
that's why you've made no progress and
so I actually recommend you guys go back
through the class you can go back
through get in touch I tell you what
just stay on hold Madison will sign you
up and we'll put you back through the
class because that's what needs to
happen you you did it you flunked
because the whole purpose in tension
peace universities get on a budget and
you hadn't done that yet since March and
this is September and that's why you
don't you make enough money and you
still don't have a thousand dollars and
it's not the car payments and it's not
the medical bills it's the living out of
control that's what's done it to you and
so and your husband and you both have
got to be working on
this and that's the only way this is
going to work